I just wanted to do right by her because
I am still here
my sister's name was Heather she passed
away from pancreatic cancer I lost my
brother on my 10th birthday I lost my
brother just suicide and his name was
Harry I lost my brother when he was 16
years old in a car accident I have a lot
of memories of him just tickling me so
hard that I couldn't breathe
she was sarcastic and sassy and the
smartest person that I might ever know
his friends are still in contact with me
today and every time they see me they
tell me how much I look like him when I
think about him I think of him as he was
which is like a teenager and then when I
dream about him he's almost always like
a baby whenever he's in my dreams I'll
like pick him up like just hold him
that's really nice we found out during
my birthday party that he was found dead
I looked down at my phone and my little
sister had just called and it's kind of
one of those things that you can't
describe but you just know he and my
grandmother decided to take a road trip
together I remember very vividly seeing
my grandfather and the police officer
walked through my back door happened
about a year ago and I got a message
from him and made the decision to drive
home so I got to see him
and then it happened the next morning I
called my sister back and she let me
know that Heather was gone but it was
just the hardest thing to watch my mom
her being in bed and just crying and
crying and my grandfather just said
there was an accident Avada my initial
instinct was to want to talk to her
immediately and I can't tell you how
many times I actually picked to the
phone I went oh no that number doesn't
work anymore it's been over a year but
it it doesn't feel like over here it
feels like I was like yesterday you know
it took me a long time to stop
entertaining the thought that maybe it
wasn't real there's always the questions
of like well if I was home if I was
closer like what I have been able to do
anything and there are moments that you
are so fine and then the next second for
no reason
you were like a crying heap on the floor
when I feel myself go into the pain of
it I allow myself to because I think
that that's important it doesn't matter
how much I heal or how much emotional
processing I go through or how much I
pray or go to therapy or whatever he's
still gone if you wait for that sadness
to go away like it won't I think the
only way to make it completely go away
would be to forget about him I know this
is cliche but honestly I think about him
every day there's not a day that goes by
that I don't think about her I don't
know that it will really ever feel
normal cuz I'm gonna can that sort of
empty space in my life it's still there
it's still an empty space but it doesn't
feel so glaring anymore it's like a
heavy heavy weight but maybe the weight
is still heavy and I just have gotten
stronger it doesn't get easier
it gets more manageable